americans are not being hospitalized
with the omicron variant at the same
rate as other strains but it is still
dangerous including for kids the u.s now
averages 260 pediatric covet
hospitalizations a day that is up nearly
30 percent from last week meg oliver is
in paterson new jersey meg good morning
nate good morning that rise in cases and
hospitalizations has some school
districts like karen patterson switching
to all remote for two weeks after winter
break some say the solution isn't
keeping kids out of the classroom but
getting shots into arms
as the omicron variant continues to
sweep across the northeast unvaccinated
of all ages are at increased risk in new
york state health officials say
pediatric hospitalizations in new york
city rose nearly five-fold from the
start of december and almost all of the
children were unvaccinated
we need to get child vaccinations up
we need to get them higher than they are
particularly in the 5 to 11 year old age
group in new york state roughly 27
percent of 5 to 11 year olds are
vaccinated nationwide that number falls
to roughly 23 percent new york
presbyterian chief pediatrician dr sally
permar the vaccine is so much safer than
getting the virus itself and so giving
your child the vaccine keeps them safer
than letting them get infected with this
virus without any immunity from a
vaccine while hospitals typically see a
rise in pediatric admissions this time
of year dr permar says parents should
take omicron seriously
how serious are their symptoms
well serious enough to be admitted to
the hospital which again is an
indication that this is not just a
disease of adults what do you think
should happen in terms of reopening
schools now that you're seeing a spike
in cases among kids yeah i think we know
so much more about how to keep our
children safe and we also learned how
devastating it is to keep children out
of school so i think we should use all
the tools we have implement vaccination
for all the school kids also use testing
also use masks
and our typical hand washing and social
distancing to keep kids in school even
with this rising cases
new york governor kathy hokel also
announced yesterday she's urging all
superintendents to keep their classrooms
open she says she's prepared to send any
additional resources they may need to
prevent any interruptions to in-person
learning jamie
meg thank you